you're responsible for your child I
didn't want to be the manager obviously
you didn't want to be involved you want
to be there nobody's going to care about
the needs of your child like you nobody
might say they they have that best
interest at heart but they don't they
can't they can't because they have
another agenda and part of that is maybe
to benefit your child's career but you
have to help discern like what is that
coming from what's the reason is that a
good reason is that a valid reason we
have amazing people on the team but you
know again like they weren't coming from
the same place of caring about not just
her career but her her Legacy her when
and why that I mean what you do for the
world and how you do it and that
includes like your merch and every
single decision you make and she was
also young and making mistakes and being
a human being you know in the age of
Twitter and everywhere else you know
also I'm her mom like who's she gonna
get mad at they're taking kind of all of
it out on you and you're like oh my gosh
I really want to run away but I have to
stay here because I actually have to
protect you